is comercial de televisão comercial de
televisão acho engraçado porque tem uns
candidatos muito avulso que eles não
sabem falar com a câmera eles não tem
sabe meu nome é Jeferson da cacimba meu
número é
4769 Vote em o cara não termina nem o
Vote em mim que os cara corta não tem
tempo os candidatos tem que falar tão
ligeiro que tem que falar assim ó meu
número é 3 9997 eu sou um candidato
muito indicado em casa e suspeito de
dente só também sempre tem uns artistas
que deixaram de ser famosos sabe já
caíram no esquecimento Mas eles querem
voltar sendo políticos e eles sempre vem
acompanhado com um Logan de merda meu
nome é Jamilton 777 sou ex-jogador do
Bragantino por uma cidade mais esportiva
em época de eleição o que tem chove no
meio da rua aqueles carros com paródia
de política e os caras são ligeiro meu
amigo lançou a música Os caras peia a
paródia
malandramente Zé firin inocente fez as
faltos pra gente Para nós poder dirigir
malandramente botou telha lá em casa
ajudou com as compras PR nós poder
curtir